[Música]
[Aplausos]
to se aquele feito de tchau
que de mim
[Música]
e aí galera que fechou o canal tudo com
vocês como está a delícia isso é
exatamente uma hora da tarde eu já não
sei né ô coisa bola é comer eu gosto
muito e comecei eu sou legítimo barriga
nos olha aquele medo de botar comida do
prato a mãe ficar de olho itu não vai
começar aí eu não vou eu tô com fome ou
isso no bota mais do que tudo então
inventou um foco metade isso aqui vai
botar o próprio tamanho da serra da
capivara e comendo como é chegar na
metade do prato é o time se encher de
manhã aqui ó
não comece eu tô com fome e eu comento
aqui olha populares para a mãe sair cada
que vai sair fumo e fez o comerciante e
gostou
dinho só que aqui pessoa que estiver de
carro ao todo 200 km da cidade tem
nenhum tento pelo vegetação não tem uma
alma viva num lugar sem meu carro
quebrar a primeira que o pescoço eu
tivesse problema marmitas em que o carro
estava com medo porque tem que comer cá
o que o mundo conspira para você nem
começou a mãe não quer que você conte a
prestar atenção que quando a mãe quer
que você não como as com ela inventa que
não pode comer você é criança beleza
maicon meu mandato é não comer manga ou
votar de tomar o leite ou não a mãe pelo
amor de deus né fumando não meu filho
leite com maria farmall uma farmácia
ficassem com o mesmo não pode nem fumava
no pódio pode por que reza a lenda que
quem bebe leite com manga morre século
nessa o cara cavou chega à lanchonete
teve também de manhã com ele eu nunca vi
uma pessoa que morreu de manga com leite
do meu filho o vice de futebol e morreu
de quê mulher mulher cheguei em casa vi
os carros
manga um copo é esse no chão quebrada o
tanto que eu avisei não bebe leite com
manga não desgarrar também mulher que
queria ficar aqui embaixo dos pés de
manhã como é que a economia não
influenciei eu sou a favor de como comer
bem é comer bem mesmo é muito a número
normal que haja comida de restaurante é
o prato raso branco sem graça e como é
que esse prato mesmo fundo que esse
prato fundo o que é tão rápida que está
tudo errado que a gente bota comida e
provar acabou na comida a gente quer
colocar o resto é o resto de comida o
que sobrou na colher e não sobe pra
colher que é o prato não tem borda é
liso não quer comer pra turista quer
comer um prato fundo é preciso comer
galiza jogar a comida na mesa comer com
a mão em cima da mesa tem como prato
fundo ou mesmo como a carioca quando a
carga de volta os pratos de alumínio a
coisa mais linda os pratas da casa de
volta à facada voz própria alumínio
fundo para essa bacia a ganhar duas
rosas no fundo para a roda toda
arranhada de faca só pensei fome atacou
fome meta faca na tam em abuja não come
madrugada ajuda as pessoas havendo ajuda
na saúde não compre madrugasse como
madrugada acorda cidade não tem a gente
não dá valor quando você cresce você não
dá valor a comida é como criança criança
três camaradas valor comida no mundo ele
sente o cheiro de um pacote de biscoito
800 quilômetros de distância 7 méxico
por um picolé no décor de chupar um
picolé inter e jogar picolé fora no
outro dia quando bater a fome passa o
dia inteiro pensando no picolé que a
gente jogou forte a criança quer comer
alguma coisa e alguém estiver chegando
vez ela divide ela come todo o dia e só
para dar conta pessoal aqui tomando a
viana é bom colaborou e ainda aí ela não
ele não pôde também de uma nota acabando
amar efeito da novidade também quando
tiver do também é totalmente só aí
quando eu tô comendo coisas
também tudo me dá também também já fui
pedindo também 11 a cuspir aqui como é
bom te dar nossa maneira a deus perdoa o
bebê continuar bem aqui eu te dou tá bom
tá bom é milimetricamente medido até um
pouquinho aí falou também de minas
também o record também corre agora é
toda a novela cara focado um pouco em
negócio que é meu amigo mas caiu adoro
uma churrascaria na colônia
churrascarias geralmente por aqueles
bife eu prefiro estar no nome de frango
gosta muito estrago não foi eu amo e
chegou nada de frango batata pai eu
chego no restaurante a primeira coisa
que eu peço depor na cei dói faial está
no norte de frança não vai pra mim é o
tempero da comida roupa moço é iguaçu
vai files e hoje está assim ai fire ou
sem fome já que na churrascaria você
consegue ver os níveis de felicidade de
um garçom pode deixar de ser um cara que
vem com a picanha raven sorri todo mundo
ama picanha roupa
ganha quem quer contar uma piada pela na
cozinha ele está feliz porque ele vai
com um espeto de picanha e volta só com
um espeto nunca picanha do contrafilé
que também vem sorrindo nec por todo
mundo à vontade como é o caso do
fraldinha ele natalie sem expressão tá
eu tô aí o cara do carneiro do carneiro
já vem mais ou menos assim que todo
mundo gosta de carne de porco carneiro é
o caso do cupim o cara que preocupe já é
um cara mais velho ele sabe que só vai
como cupim vai ter um tinha um voo na
mesma fez negócio com br você percebe
que da picanha pulp o nível de
felicidade de seu o cara do javali faz
que vem com depressão e vem empurrando
um carrinho de javali inteiro a estaiada
que vivem com alguém quer saber como é
que alguém da carne de javali não gosta
[Música]
da atenção por não ser complicado você
tá cheio de picante não quer mais
picanha o que faz e diz não publicação
vira um negócio geralmente leva em conta
na mesa se eu não servir não cara chega
picanha se o canal obrigado meu caso do
javali ninguém responde quem já falei e
não competiram na prova e 682 pontos 7 é
é tão atacada lei do cinema no rádio nas
provas
já falei abel já falei aqui
melhor que o caso já vai se revoltar
homem precisa que não entendeu o que faz
na derrota do botafogo na quinta já
falei vocês pensam que a escolhe o
google eu você é por isso que eu
pergunto vocês que já vai sendo que já
fez fala que não quer já valente vai
fazer chegar à direita alguém quer jogar
aqui é coisa minha eu ficar no cargo de
ambo e hamburg adoro vocês só permite
propaganda o bob's é uma maneira bonita
de bola passar na televisão pensar me
conhece é só me conhece no meio da rua a
caminho do sanduíche o vasco onde com o
sanduíche bola no gol segue avançando e
chefiou um pouquinho aqui ó
olha eu a peguei muito cara o bob's
papel em um sonho do mês com meu novo
sanduíche meu meu do meu estilo do
jeitinho que eu gosto não gosto do
estilo pilsen gostoso nenê ligada àquele
pãozinho estilo italiano mesmo quem
tinha só na hora dois hambúrgueres sabor
picanha beco houve nem todo mundo vinha
maionese e ficar bem cremoso quintal e o
cara lá que é muito fã e disse eu
conseguisse meio milhão de likes nesse
vídeo e atenção do bom meu mesmo então
se tiver mais que meio milhão de likes e
vão lançar o bob's o irão é isso aí já
metlife aqui e agora com o que eu tenho
hoje é que eu tô sonhando que eu vou
comer e alguém me acorda o cara quer
dormir de novo a voltar por cima e
tentar comer as coisas em volta não tem
mais a cabeça da gente assim ele vê você
quer ir lá tu quer que o menino e quando
vai ter comida mas não executar um sonho
que há como estimar que o mesmo um
banquete é uma coisa tão linda quando eu
fui com o mesmo tempo item
o influente está comendo comecei a subir
subir flutuar faltou acordei o papai ou
eles a escola apae vai pra deixar o
menino com o meu negócio era titular me
pergunto isso qual é o teu sonho que o
cara que é meu sonho fosse aquelas
comidas que eu recomendo aquele sonho de
me acordar se tornar realidade esse
seria um sonho se tornar realidade se
você gostou e se viram esquece que
gostei aqui no youtube como a sauber
williams só vota lá no facebook você viu
de novo eu gostei de comer clique em
curtir lá e marca seus amigos só pensa
em comer então junto clique gostei é
nóis painel e que quer